as a technologist i really value my
research time and often i dedicate some
specific time to learn something new
that i don't know
and often it starts with a new acronym
hello my name is jamil spain brand
technical specialist with the u.s
financial services market and our topic
for today is
what is etl
now the way i like to break this down is
first define what this acronym means
and then we'll discuss
the benefits and why it's so important
to actually implement into your
architecture
so we're going to start it off with a
little bit of cheer first give me that e
the e stands for
extract
when you do etl you're going to be
bringing in data from a variety of
different data sources and the goal once
you have all them together you're going
to do that t
for transform
once that data is all together you do
the process of decoupling
denormalizing combining reshifting data
that you never had the perspective to
put together before now you have your
own playground to really start to make
some new relationships maybe you'll
throw in a little bit of relational
database some sql in there to do some
processing as well
finally
the last one give me that l
stands for load so after you have this
new view
new perspective on your data you're
going to want to load that
new curated data into another data
source
so now that we know what etl means the
next obvious question is why is this so
important and as technologies we like to
invest our time into things we know
we're going to get the value out of as
well
so the first let's talk about benefits
over here that we're gonna see
the next is gonna the first one is gonna
give you
context so
as you work with the data you're gonna
now have deep historical data
based upon your specific
application
specifically for your use case that
you'll have
and with that will come a certain
consolidation
of all your data that you will have
having all that data in one place
really
gives you the perfect ground for
analysis and reporting
and having it all available to
constantly update and still be there for
you
now as i think about what etl
accomplishes think about what it takes
to do that manually you can probably
guess what this p is for
and that is for productivity
okay
at some point you will probably have to
if you did not have etl you have to
manually do all this together and so
you're going to come up with a
repeatable process you just keep feeding
data in and it comes out giving you the
context and also
giving you the perfect
analysis ready
view for you to use
all right and the last that you can
think of the a
is for accuracy
so definitely
as you build all this information you
have the concept the context
of your data it's already consolidated
it's repeatable you keep feeding data in
now when i want to do my long-running
reporting i want to base my nice fancy
charts off this data or maybe you want
to get into situations where you have
auditing or reporting standards that you
must provide this data you have all this
information coming from different
sources already curated constantly
feeding in
so
when it comes whether you're starting
your first data warehouse project or
your existing warehouse or you're doing
your application you're generating large
amounts of data consider etl and what it
can do for you
thank you for your time
if you have questions please drop us a
line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe